you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman just come
and I just got paired up playing a 5-2
game so let's see what we got let's try
a Sicilian it should be five no open
Sicilian cleaner night
no okay she's talking about this
recently that I don't really have a good
setup against Queen tasty for that's a
bit of a surprising move um used to
seeing Bishop b5 in reply so my Knights
pinned thinking about just e6 I don't
see a reason to break the pin just yet I
could always play Bishop d7 yeah let's
go with this right away you know it
seems a little bit awkward because when
I do play this the Queen seems like
she's gonna have to move again let me do
this right now I'm a bit fearful of a
quick queenside castle Knight b5 stuff
putting pressure here I want to have
this rook defended so my knight could
move and throw a punch at the Queen okay
just get another developing move in
Knight f6 hmm I feel like I should be
able to
Queen somehow she's kind of short on
squares I have two bishops pointing
towards the Queen side a6 b5 night here
d5 stuff hmm let's start with this
weakens b6 but I'm looking to expand
here and I feel like I should do this
right now I know I don't have a lot of
development in I'm trying to take
advantage of this Queen being short on
squares might be a sacrifice here I'll
just have to run with it okay happy to
see that move so they're fearing their
queen getting trapped alright let's get
another developing move in go inside
castle Queen c7 that's a pretty slow
move it's there to preserve the bishop
let's get another developing move in if
we continue like this I'm fine with this
position yeah this Queen is misplaced
I'm pretty sure can I trap her already I
don't think so
it's just finished development so we
both connect our book our Brooks
back-to-back moves and the Queen's
running into this move
Knight a5 into c4 this seems logical
let's put the rook here prepare to post
a knight up here on c4 making a lot of
Queen moves but doing so pretty fast
let's get this rook here maybe even
consider a 5 B 4 rattle the knight
position staying flexible some I can't
do this just yet
let's get this move in opens the major
pieces eyes they're moving very fast
that's that's for sure how about we look
for a d5 break I think this is a good
opportunity to reposition my bishop I
don't want to be too quick to jump in
here they play b4 that'd be pretty
weakening my knight would have to go to
a pretty awkward Square but there's a
lot of weaknesses created so is this not
an opportunity for me to play straight
in with the d5 I think it is let's do it
this also supports night c4 this is
growing in appeal let's get the night on
d7 cuz now on takes I'm gonna take away
from the center well both ways are
interesting but I like opening up my
bishop here and trying to play towards
their king should I jump in right now
I'm pretty sure at any moment I could do
this hmm I'm just gonna run with it
right away they gave up their bishop
okay they're not okay this Knight isn't
such a great piece how about we improve
him some okay so there they go
taking my knight too and that's a good
square but I could kind of recycle him
by way of d7 very weakening move b3 is
hit let's preserve my bishop and stay
out of both Brookes way
they continue to play fast where's the
snake going the back rank this is a
sensitive point hmm I want to drop him
and I want to be able to move my knight
I don't want to move him because I give
up the be 5 square wow I feel like none
of my moves are good like how fast
White's playing uh okay I think I just
want to still just jump right in here
yeah I gotta let these guys see so
doubled pawns but I have this this guy
right here he's backward
the Queen's ready to get hit again huh
going right into a queen takes pawn
Knight here okay
hmm let's step over here this is an open
file
things have changed some and there they
go
could I just play feels like there
should be some tactic right around the
corner
what about pawn takes rough taste let's
than on minute almost just a minute here
okay we're gonna go with this and then
get out of the pen as soon as possible
I'm prepared to just give up a pawn if
they challenge them I'm going to jump
right in
maybe even right now hmm maybe I should
contest this file some let's do this
first don't think I'm running into any
tactics just yet maybe hmm
okay I'm gonna hop right in I think
right now is the time to do it still
though well I have the bishops
yeah let's take care I did consider this
move for a just a little bit and just
right here hmm not a lot of time let's
trade one rook yeah and then maybe
Bishop here could I get away with that
just getting the pawn back gotta try
something in fast okay maybe Queen here
hits with some double attack it would
threaten mate maybe I can make it happen
so that it hits something else
let's get a flight square in not the
greatest flight square but gonna go with
it gotta go with something 12 seconds
and yep it's flying let's put the bishop
here
I think Queen here there be Knight f3
G's need to slow down man alright I
guess we're gonna try this okay oh I
totally missed that move and I'm gonna
be busted now because I'm in a pen oh
that's just busted I should resign man
oh I didn't even find a way to take
advantage of that he's playing really
fast
and I wasn't able to do anything I know
that there was something there with
the going back right here let me go
right into the analysis hmm because the
Queen drifting over like that there's no
way that that should be survivable let
me flip the board Queen a4 is a little
bit awkward because as mentioned I think
this is uh this is the way my bishop
wants to go anyhow d7 and then into c6
and now d7 is all of a sudden hitting at
the Queen but I didn't find a way to
punish what light did here and this
should be punishable if there's if
there's some way to take advantage of
blacks setup it would be early on
because white has or I should say I have
a lag in development so they didn't do
that there were these h3 and a three
moves to secure the Queen h3 to secure
the bishop from Knight g4 and they put a
lot of pressure on me on the clock but I
like the position I got here I'm pretty
sure d5 is the move maybe maybe there's
an adjustment right around here instead
of d5 something else but it felt so
natural to do that maybe I could hold
off and drop my bishop back to a8 here
and just not be too quick to let's say
have the center lock up yeah maybe
there's an adjustment with my frame of
mind here where you know what I would
really like to have happen is upon
exchange in the center and have this
position open up so that I could better
emphasize my Queen placement over
there's she's clearly offside on a2 and
maybe if it opens up my Queen will be
able to be put to use in the center or
even towards the Kings side so a bit of
a mentality change right around here
instead of d5 maybe just hold off just
improve get out get out of the Queen and
rooks way here's another
approach that said d5 I don't think can
be bad I jump into c4 I think they're
smart not to take because I was going to
go like this the queen is that much more
out of play I have the two bishops an
opposed bishop pointing right at g2 hmm
but where did it really go wrong I mean
once they got c3 and the rook is active
I don't know if I'm missing any tactics
we're gonna find out with the computer
but being like this move here Queenie
for a knight c5 and then she returns so
but I'm doing nothing to to punish this
type of play hmm yeah they're getting
the C file open up now Queen d7 mm-hmm
I'm down upon now but I still felt like
I was alright because I have this bishop
here hmm
something could have already been
adjusted I'm sure before we're even at
this point I held out from Queen d5
because after Knight f6 I just wasn't
sure how to approach this what's the
what's the follow-up move here I didn't
really see it also I should mention I
didn't have time to really share it
during the game but when it came time to
make a flight square normally I'll look
into what color Bishop is remaining and
make a flight square of the opposite
color well I did do that with h6
producing a light square but for the
moment it's actually controlled by the
Queen what my fear is is by going with
g6 is that this Bishop could enter my
position if he's getting to f6 this is
big big trouble my king will never be
safe so that's why I'm going with h6
even though for the moment it's a flight
square that's currently under White's
control
I still think that this is the way
forward the way to provide a a new
square for my king and I don't know what
more to say this was a bit of a shocking
move just ignoring my threat against the
rook Bishop takes rook
they have Knight takes rook and why not
do that Bishop here and where's he going
that's one way to win it oh I didn't see
that how could I have better seen that
one
just taking the rook night here and
recognizing a knight on the edge here
possibilities to trap him especially
when you have two bishops mmm a knight
that's hit twice currently oh I would
have wet and been a way to do it
just take the rook right here and call
White's Bluff call call white out on
their fast moved into c6 hmm went
downhill from here didn't it because I'm
lost with this skewer and I shouldn't
have played here I had to go to this
square but even so yeah I went to this
square this is probably tending towards
the draw then just with the rooks I
defended on the wrong square and I'm
pretty sure they should have just
captured like this but they pushed and I
think that this is still winning fur for
white because even if I attack the rook
there's this move and if I'm playing
here okay it's getting a little bit more
complicated but it's these complications
are unnecessary I needed to when it got
to this point I needed to play into the
d5 square
but they put a lot of pressure on me as
you saw on the clock and well let's have
a look at it with stockfish and see
where we can make some improvements ok
stockfish show me the way these losses
are painful to say the least
alright I don't think there's anything
wrong with the the setup I'm taking here
with having this small pawn Center hey
six is fine be five right away is fine
I'd have six okay nothing was missed out
of the opening I mean once once these
pieces are building up I think we're
gonna see just a growing advantage for
black castles we both complete our
development yeah be four to move I
didn't consider I was too fixated on I
referenced a 5 B 4 I could go b4 right
away and put Knight a5 into c4 is
another idea bishop c6 I played Bishop
c6 Queen b7 hmm that I didn't consider I
went for d5 and that's what it's
suggesting ok I think I was pointing out
bishop AAA and just holding up I could
afford a slow move like that just
clearing the way for these major pieces
but d5 right away is fine he 597 Knight
c4 ah okay
and now Bishop d7 I think I played
Bishop a 8 here no Knight c5 okay Knight
e4 okay this is interesting my nights
under 5 but they're suggesting naive for
hmm taking advantage
this unprotected piece on Knight takes
I'm taking with the pawn pawn takes
Knight I'm smashing through against
their Kings side that's that would
definitely be nice I could saddle them
with some structural defect over there
and I could with that variation well if
they are if they are taking here and I
guess maybe they're having to take no
because I'm also unmasking my bishop on
a3 which is now hit twice mmm so this
was a pretty clever move here clever
suggestion by the computer naive 4 I
retreated okay just a small advantage
now it's back to something a bit more
substantial 0.38 ish Bishop g4 being
called out for looking for some tactics
here maybe now Bishop d3 okay what more
maybe to d7 94 would have been a nice
find nothing okay now there's something
here huh Knight takes e5 what Knight
takes e5 oh wow oh what's the idea here
just to play this move next and cut off
the bishop from defending the knight and
also preparing Bishop d6 okay um clearly
that didn't run through my mind but what
can we maybe say about sacrifices like
this they're they're pretty little wild
tactics like this are there maybe quite
likely in in these position types where
the Queen is just out of play
and she is definitely out of place she's
hemmed in over here by some pawns and
not contributing so much she really just
functions at least for the moment as if
she's only a bishop
and that's that's interesting sacking a
night for those two ponds and now
there's some serious threats of these
bishops functioning pointing right at
the White King suggests king h1 III
Knight f3 takes here Bishop g3 some odd
suggestions but I guess in the end I'm
going to be getting the piece back huh
here I take there this isn't the the
move that I would really question king
h1 I would what's the human-like move
it's to secure the night with maybe oh I
don't know Bishop here but then there's
Bishop d6 sneaking in here rook F for
Brooke c3 okay so it's a bit it's a bit
complicated to say the least but as
mentioned sacrifices like that when the
Queen is a bit misplaced they may very
well be there didn't go for that I went
for the human move like c5 knowing that
there is no Queen takes pawn because
there's 93 hitting the Queen
so she's goes back and now III within
the idea of 94 okay
missed opportunities here one more jump
in now I'm giving up a pawn but just
temporarily I do get it back it's
nothing significant advantage wise now
with age six oh5 as well huh did pop up
h5 it's going back and forth I don't
know if I could really work out the
reasons behind each I don't really I
mean some in some cases let's say let's
say White was playing with
I was going to say if white is playing
with the light square bishop I might be
more inclined to play h5 so that I mean
if I'm playing h5 let me say like this
if I'm playing h5 I have in mind two
things one is clearly the flight square
but I might want to squeeze a little bit
more out of the H pawn by playing into
h4 to have one pawn restrict to but I
really don't see that taking shape in a
position where there's a dark square
Bishop if I'm ever here
the bishop could put pressure on the
pawn and he may turn out to be a
liability or you know in the end drop
off so I'm just going a single step King
h2 and it's just even though and I
thought I could just take the rook here
am I missing I thought in before I
looked at it with a computer I thought
this and on Knight takes rook I would be
playing Bishop d5 that's true so was
this calculated here I think they
probably would have captured my rook
instead of this guess the idea is that
they're going to get the bishop
there's still this fork present in and
rook c8 there's 97 I don't know if they
really worked all that out I'm guessing
that they they saw it as if they take if
I take their Rick they're gonna take
mine okay well this isn't winning
because of Queen c4 and there's the fork
if Rick c8 there's 97 okay
I took the rook I went down here and it
should be a draw although no there is
some advantage for white huh I need to
be taking with the bishop yeah okay
because on this they could play rook
takes pawn yeah rook takes pawn in this
position no no that's gonna be a draw it
takes takes yeah this should be ending
as a draw bishop II won I need to play
rook d5 I didn't and this is just losing
now it's still losing after b4 no yeah
before is another way to do it
okay they put a lot of pressure on me
with the clock I liked the opening how I
played it just needed to play faster but
maybe I wouldn't have gotten that
position if I played a little bit faster
it's unfortunate this is this is the
type of play you'd like to punish the
Queen kind of floating about but didn't
quite happen in this one okay well as
usual feel free to leave any feedback in
the comment section below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you